to whom it may concern
first and foremost i would like to offer
congratulations to each and every member
of staff working here
when i set out upon that gravel path i
never once thought we could break space
and time in such ways as we have
the amount we've created is something i
once believed unthinkable
and yet there is still more we can bring
into being
our work is far from complete
and there are many steps mandatory
before we can even consider the notion
of quitting
over the course of our experimenting
we've discovered possibly innumerable
ways in which the universe can be
destroyed
and ways in which we can contain the
fragments
everything we've done from the hateful
star to the telekill alloy has been a
complete success
through all this
i wish the foundation many many years of
success to come
that is not the point of this letter
the point of this letter is to inform
you all
of the success of my latest experiment
yes
i have continued my research into the
unknown
before i tell you about this one however
i must delve into my reasoning for this
experiment
the idea for this particular line of
research came to me about six months
after we'd started
i was worried
yes i know that's out of character for a
man with so much power
but i was worried
you see we've been creating all of these
wonderful things
but we had to be secretive we had to
make sure that no one would know
as the months dragged by this worry
festered
it's always going to raise suspicions
when you disappear almost entirely and
reappear several months later as the
head of a huge company
every time i heard a rumor that a
certain scp was man-made it sent a
shiver down my spine
i paced up and down my lab wondering how
to best cover my
tracks didn't want to be punished for
advancing human knowledge
i wanted to keep a firm grip on this
control until i died
as did all the others
we worked together we arranged for some
of the entities to be found
and we wrote the reports for the others
this was not enough
i had to find a way to ensure that no
one could ever find me or anyone around
me out
i soon hit upon an incredible
idea
what if i could erase myself from
official
existence
i know i'm making it sound like i wanted
to kill myself i
wasn't planning on ending my life i was
planning on wiping myself
from the official documents making it
seem that i never existed at all
the best way to cover my tracks
was to destroy them entirely
it took a few months of solid hard work
but i finished
i found a way to make it look like i'd
never officially existed it was
dangerous i'll not lie
i constructed a faraday cage around my
lab for protection
due to the potentially volatile nature
of the experiment instructed everyone to
stay clear of my room
and got to work
it worked
it worked far too well
my suspicions were first raised when my
own brother walked into the room
and was surprised to see that i was
there
i was confused but i assume he'd just
forgot that i was there
i went to the cafeteria and found
people trying to work out when we built
that faraday cage
i ignored them as i hadn't told many
people that i was building it
when i found an official document
detailing the room that i was in that's
when i realized something was wrong
i'd been classified
as an scp
i didn't erase myself from the official
documents
i'd erased myself from existence
entirely
people came into my lab to take
photographs of me to converse with me to
figure out what i was
high-level researchers my friends my
brother didn't recognize me anymore
no one could remember me
even hours after the 50th visit
i continued my work
i made more of these things and put them
in containment almost immediately i
noticed
that people had no idea where they came
from
not the official documentation of course
i'd handled that but more specifically
thomas and my brother were discussing in
hushed tones how they hadn't created
those ones
at that point the realization of what
i'd done
my reason for creating the foundation
and what it contains at first was
discovery to discover what we could do
if we bent reality to see if we could
improve lives
now of course it's a different story for
the others
some of them are in it for personal gain
some for more that discovery we yearned
after in the beginning
even more for a chance to create the
impossible
however
even that doesn't explain my reasoning
the thing is
after bending the laws of physics so
many times
i got used to playing god
now i get to be one
i get to manipulate reality from behind
the scenes
i classified myself as ketter to see how
you'd react to the idea of something
potentially world ending completely
fading from my memory
i edited myself into the official
document and how we started although you
won't remember my name being there
i've told everyone that i'm not circular
and that's the only thing you remember
about me anymore
while the number of scps i've created is
quite small the number of ideas i gave
birth to
is tremendous
i started manipulating people too
i started discussing with high-ranking
researchers that i told to come into my
room
what else they could do with scps
how they could worship machines
make art
mass market them from profit or just
destroy them when they left they forgot
about me but they remembered my ideas
they assumed that the ideas were theirs
and so they saw them out
it was almost like brainwashing
it gave me more power
power that i've lusted after since the
beginning of the foundation
i'm controlling all of these people
even you
you see after reading this letter
you'll rush off and go tell someone
along the way you'll drop the letter and
forget where it is you're going
you could be the first person to read it
you could be the hundredth
it doesn't matter
after this you go back to being nothing
but a pitiful powerless pawn
created for the sole purpose of testing
by control
everything that the foundation and any
of the other groups has done
is down to me and me alone
sometimes i come up with ideas and tell
other researchers
sometimes i create them and put them in
containment
i organize outbreaks to test the might
of my creations
every idea
every thought you have ever had in your
measly
unimportant
waste of a life is either known or made
by me
and me alone
i know that you consider me evil or
unjust
or corrupt
i know you believe that this
is unacceptable and a gross misuse of
power
the truth is
mortal gods do not adhere to the same
restrictive moral code as you
insignificant
insects yours forgettably
aaron
siegel
[Music]
you